what's the most beautiful thing about
running to you
why do you love it i think uh there's
kind of a couple directions
to look at it through or lenses looking
through there's like the in the moment
right
there's always going to be that run
where uh you're clicking along and
things just feel great
you get some endorphins and you get the
you know the
the quote unquote runners high and that
sort of stuff and that's like just like
this
great feeling that you can kind of tap
into on the like real like
like in the moment type of level uh you
know you've
my wife and i talk about this because
she's a competitive ultra runner as well
and
um you'll we'll have a day where you
know we'll take a forced day off or
something like that and it's necessary
right it's gonna
allow the enjoyment to continue but
you get into this like routine of i wake
up in the morning i do this run and that
kind of gets my day started that gets my
my energies up i get that runner's high
afterwards he removed that from the
equation for a rest day
and you just sort of like uh man i don't
feel like i never got started today like
yeah
you know it's just this weird thing it's
almost i think it's it's funny because
non-runners don't always like
necessarily recognize it because for
them it's the complete opposite they're
like if i can get away from
not having to run today that's going to
be a good day versus
yeah but it's one of those things that i
think gets more addictive the more you
do it so
uh so that's purely from the running
perspective there's this joy
of of the runner's high of the post
after the run you feel like you can take
on the world that kind of thing
yes and i think that's one of the
drivers from just a quality of life
standpoint
uh just uh you know and in the moment
immediate gratification
uh standpoint but then there's like i
think the bigger picture stuff for the
longer term stuff
and for me that enjoyment is like
just the process like of uh okay i'm
starting at this
fitness level and i'm gonna do these
workouts and by doing these workouts i'm
going to see incremental progress from
them
and then that's another kind of like
kind of short-term gratification that's
maybe a little longer than the
day-to-day but
um still like shorter than like a career
or a
or a build up for a particular race
where you're saying you're seeing
yourself like okay maybe i'm focusing on
short intervals right now
and on week one i covered this much
distance in three minutes but by week
four i'm covering this much distance and
you can just see that progress
it's almost like uh in elementary school
when you get the gold star for reading a
book it's like did that gold star really
mean anything
i don't know but i felt great when they
gave it to me yeah
there's something about just finding
improvement and people love to see
improvement i think so
that's where i think you can also get
some value and it would be saying like i
started here and i got there
you